Wait, this is a
recipe with quite a few pitfalls.
I'll check the progress at each stage, so do it carefully. I'll look after Nanao as usual.
After asking, there's no need for me to intervene. I've
done my homework properly, but Pete's definitely not going to do it.
No need to mess with it.
Okay, now that's over. What are you
doing? You put in too many bubble glasses. Let the
kid wash his eyes with olive oil. You
have to close the lid right away.
[Music]
That's 10 times as much water.
[Applause]
[Music]
That's an accurate response.
Your name
is Oliver Fong. It's a
pseudonym, but it's from a family of several companies. But you
have good taste. Every response
shows the extent of your daily training. I remember your face and name.
Thank you Mr. 4,
but I would like to give you a piece of advice: You
should be selective about the friends you hang out with.